the flag of Serbia Serbian chants and
nationalistic music but this isn't
Serbia it's Northern Kosovo and tensions
remain outside local government
buildings where ethnically Albanian
Mayors tried to take office ethnic serbs
who make up the majority here boycotted
the vote and have been protesting
against them
once again we request that today's
Gathering proceeds peacefully as we are
renowned for our peaceful nature now I
kindly asked these individuals to and
follow the most beautiful and cherished
flag of our nation the Serbian flag
the protests have not been peaceful we
witnessed the Kosovo police vehicle
being attacked as well as the vehicles
of journalists the U.S and NATO have
criticized Kosovo for increasing
tensions after its police forced their
way into local government buildings the
U.S says it has asked the elected Mayors
to take office in alternate buildings
and for the police to leave the vicinity
there are parallel structures in the
northern part of our country
if I would now order Mayors to leave
that office into another office
somewhere elsewhere it would be as if I
am engaging in creating sort of a
parallel structure to parallel
structures
copying their method I would join their
illegality
I cannot do that Russia is a close Ally
of neighboring Serbia and is one of the
countries that has never recognized the
Independence that Kosovo declared in
we are keeping an eye on this we support
Serbia and the serbs unconditionally we
say all the legal rights and interests
of the Kosovo serve must be observed and
must be fulfilled
NATO forces are increasing their
presence in Northern Kosovo and polish
and American troops are patrolling the
streets around local government
buildings in zavechan Western Powers
have criticized kosovo's actions and
pressure on prime minister security is
growing but he faces a dilemma in trying
to defuse tensions pristine is Keen to
emphasize these northern areas are part
of Kosovo and not an extension of Serbia
even if ethnic serbs here feel say and
act otherwise Assad Kosovo